hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
fairly early in his piece the subject
and power michel foucault is going to
bring up a particular modality or a type
of power relation that he calls pastoral
power and this is of
significant scope it develops
contingently
over the course of time within the west
and then
transitions from being something that is
essentially centered in a religious
institution
and then as he says begins to pervade
the rest of society whether religious or
secular and it becomes very politically
oriented in modern times he brings this
up in relation to the
mechanisms of subjection one of the
three main kinds of
power exercised on people that he's
discussed earlier domination
exploitation and
subjection or subjectification making
people into subjects
and he tells us that since the 16th
century
new a new political form of power
has been developing continuously by the
way he says and he says this new
political structure is as everybody
knows the state right so there's a
temptation and a tendency when we're
looking at power and power relations to
focus just on the nation state as it is
developing and growing larger and larger
and perhaps even engaging in conflict
with other nation states or the
rivalries and conflicts within it and he
says most of the time the state is
envisioned as a kind of political power
that ignores individuals looking only at
the interests of the totality or i
should say a class or group among the
citizens so the individual matters in so
far as the individual perhaps has power
or has power exercised upon them so they
get in line with the rest of the state
and he says that's not you know
that's not something that doesn't exist
all of that is important but
i'd like to underline the fact that the
state's power
and one of the reasons for its strength
is both an individualizing
and a totalizing form of power and he
says never i think in the history of
human societies even in the old chinese
society has there been such a tricky
combination in the same political
structures of individualization
techniques and totalization procedures
now is that to say that everybody from
the 16th century on is living in such a
state no of course there's more and
there's less to certain degrees and
there can be societies where the state
has completely failed and other things
have stepped into the gap but this is
kind of a normative complex that he is
identifying
and then he says something really
interesting here
this is due to the fact that this
combination of individualization and
totalization
this is due to the fact that the modern
western state has integrated in
a new political
shape
an old power technique
so it's using as fuco points out we can
do in many different ways
power structures power organizations
power relations power techniques are not
usually
just within the province of one
particular institution they can be
transferred to others and thereby you
know become in some respects more
totalizing more effective
and he says that this old power
technique originated in
christian institutions and he says we
can call this power technique pastoral
power
so here's where he introduces the term
this is an idea that foucault
plays around with in a lot of places
this is not the definitive take on it
you know you could go for example to the
history of sexuality where he's tracing
the development of this
power technique as he's calling it here
but it's uh here the the in the interest
is primarily in saying well how does it
go out of its originally christian
ecclesial context
to become something almost ubiquitous in
modern societies and so foucault points
out that a lot of people have paid
attention to christianity bringing a
new ethics and you know we could come up
with all sorts of examples of this as he
in fact does in in some of his his works
as well again history of sexuality is a
great place to go for that but there's
many other resources you could turn to
and you know a prime example of this is
valuing humility and meekness
which is a transformation of
understanding of anger because
meekness it can also be translated as
mildness gentleness it's the same thing
that aristotle is discussing and nico
mccain ethics book 4 and other people
are addressing as well
we can also look at that as opposed to
the pride of the great sold individual
that aristotle discusses again in nico
mccann ethics book four
and so christianity is is introducing
some new ethical concepts some new
ethical practices but
it's also introducing new power
relations and before people start going
oh yes constantine and the institutional
church and ooh those priests they wanted
to get their hands on everybody not
that's not what fuco's actually talking
about as a matter of fact
any sort of simplistic oh everything was
great until christianity came on the
scene foucault would say well that's a
nonsense narrative and you should really
get rid of it and quit being so stupid
as to buy into that sort of thing he
wants to analyze these new power
relations which he says take place
within the framework of a new kind of
institution and this is a debatable
claim right
christianity is the only religion that
has organized itself as a church
you know we could
debate that i'm not going to bother with
that here but we could point out you
know taoist organizations in religious
taoism or the sangha and its role in
buddhism
depending on which branch we're looking
at but he says as such it postulates in
principle certain individuals can buy
their religious qualities
serve others now notice this this
negative here not as princes magistrates
prophets fortune tellers benefactors
educationalists and so on but as
pastors
now pastor originally
has this you know denotation of the
person who is taking care of the sheep
and keeping them from coming to harm
going out and you know fighting wolves
and and grabbing the sheep that have
fallen into crevices sheep are pretty
stupid animals
and it eventually comes to take on this
notion which by the way is not totally
unique to christianity or even you know
judaism and christianity we also see uh
you know
in ancient greek things uh certain kings
called the shepherds of the people right
so it's not completely
radically new but the form of power
relation is and foucault isolates out
four
main
characteristics that he discusses
so he rattles these off by saying it is
a form of power whose ultimate aim is to
assure individual salvation in the next
world as opposed he says to political
power what is political power about
holding you know exercise of power over
people getting what you want out of them
like exploitation domination um but also
improving their lives within this
particular
world so that's that's the first thing
the aim of salvation is the next world
pastoral power is not merely a form of
power that commands so this is very
interesting here
he calls this oblativ and oblation means
sacrifice right
so the past store
has to themself be ready to
lay down their life for the sake of
their flock
this is very different as he points out
from kingly power royal power which
demands a sacrifice from its subjects to
save the throne right or we might say
the power that's enshrined in
long-standing institutions where it's
it's the institution that has to survive
and if that crushes individuals or means
that they can't have a the life that
they want to live well too bad for them
the institution doesn't sacrifice for
the people the pastor
has to at least in theory
be ready to sacrifice themselves for the
life and salvation of the flock so not
just the life of the flock but the
salvation the aim that that's key here
right
he also says it's a form of power that
looks after not just and this is a very
important qualifier not just the whole
community
but each individual in particular
and not just at one point but during
their entire life so these are some very
uh
complex things that we're thinking about
here that are
packed into this very simple sentence
oftentimes power is exercised for the
good of the community and requires again
the sacrifice of the individual but this
says that the individual has to also be
focused upon
as important and not just the individual
at a certain point like oh well you're
with us you know until you turn 18 and
then
good luck you know no we stay with you
and help to counsel and shape and
perhaps even you know redirect your life
over the course of your lifetime and
when you're dying you know we give you
absolution or
you know perhaps even baptism which a
lot of people waited for in the early
church you know as well as the
other other sacrament of anointing right
so that's a very important third thing
and then the fourth leads us into the
stuff that foucault
is fascinated with
knowledge truth right the way in which
we
understand things and the ways in which
the
disciplines not just in terms of
disciplining people but the disciplines
when we think of fields of knowledge
come to develop because he says
finally this form of power cannot be
exercised without knowledge of the in
knowing the inside of people's minds
without exploring their souls so that's
sort of a i look at you part now notice
the next thing he says
without making them
reveal their innermost secrets it
implies the knowledge of the conscience
and an ability to direct it so this is
where we get to subjectification or
subjectation uh and it's it's you know
most
clear extricated from the other
aspects
sort of way
you know the pastor has to get people to
confess and confession is
an important part of this
again something we do also find in other
religious traditions foucault thinks
that it's primarily in christianity but
you know
it doesn't it doesn't undermine the
point about what he's describing here
and it's very interesting he he says
this is linked with a production of
truth
a truth of the individual himself the
truth about who you are right and what
you are
so this is what pastoral power looks
like
in in some very broad strokes
in christianity from its early origins
all the way on to the present and
foucault says you know and he's writing
this you know decades ago
you can't really say that the church is
the dominant institution within
modern life
at this point in time he says
we should distinguish between two
aspects of pastoral power the ecclesial
institutionalization that has ceased
or at least lost its fatality since the
18th century right so the old school
christianity pastoral power
and its function
its function got taken on by other
institutions
and it's spread and multiplied outside
of the ecclesial
institution and so here we can talk
about a transition
from church to state
instead of an opposition between church
and state the state
taking on and transforming the very
techniques of pastoral power
spread into as he says the whole social
body
and he says i don't think we should
consider the modern state an entity that
was developed above individuals
ignoring what they are and even their
very existence but on the contrary a
very sophisticated structure in which
individuals can be integrated
under one condition that this
individuality would be shaped in a new
form and submitted to a set of very
specific patterns it says we can see the
state as a modern matrix of
individualization not you notice he
doesn't say individuality
individualization being turned
into individuals but turned into
individuals of a certain sort with a
certain orientation right
a new form of pastoral power he tells us
and then he says let's say a few more
things about this and he makes three
really key points there's a change in
its objective it's no longer focused on
salvation in the next world he says
rather ensuring it in this world and in
this context the world salvation takes
on different meanings
think about you know the things that we
talk about today still health
well-being that is sufficient wealth
standard of living security protection
against accidents
a series of worldly aims took the place
of religious aims of the traditional
past pastorate all the more easily
because the latter had for various
reasons followed in an accessory way a
certain number of these claims think
about medicine and its welfare function
that was assured by the churches efforts
hospitals were originally religious
institutions and then they eventually
extricate themselves from that
context right so change in objective
very important then he says the
officials of pastoral power increased
this is a really important point as well
because what he's going to say here is
it's not just the state
that does this and we might think about
societies where perhaps the state is
rather weak or caught in political
gridlock or inefficient and other
institutions like corporations
are engaged in this instead right so he
says
sometimes this power was exerted by
state apparatus or a public institution
like the police right
sometimes the power was exercised by
private ventures welfare societies
benefactors generally by philanthropists
ancient institutions for example the
family were also mobilized at this time
to take on pastoral functions and there
are other things as well like medicine
you know complex structures which
included private initiatives but also
included public institutions such as
hospitals although in our time we find
that hospitals are now in at least in
america part of
a private uh
institutions or we could say private
public because they're often hot you
know hospital groups that can be owned
by
various investors right so the number of
officials engaging in pastoral power
increases and there are sometimes at
odds with each other
and then this also leads to again we see
this important fourth point here is the
third point the multiplication of the
aims and agents of pastoral power
pastoral power focused on the
development of knowledge of man around
two roles globalizing and quantitative
concerning the population you know
looking at statistics engaging in say
public planning public health the other
analytical
concerning the individual and sometimes
these could be greatly at odds with each
other
so he coming to the end of this he says
this implies that power of a pastoral
type which over centuries for more than
a millennium was linked to a defined
religious institution
spread out into the whole
social body it found support in a
multitude of institutions
instead of a pastoral power that of the
church and a political power that of the
state or whatever else was running the
show at the time
more or less linked to each other more
or less in rivalry there was an
individualizing tactic that
characterized a series of powers those
of the family medicine psychiat
psychiatry education and employers the
things that foucault himself is engaged
in
studying so we see that pastoral power
doesn't go away and foucault thinks that
it's incredibly important to study not
just for historical purposes but so we
can understand our own condition in the
presence
you